je me trouve sur la place d'armes à
versailles le château de versailles et
le département des yvelines ne viennent
de signer un protocole d'accord sur la
réalisation et le financement de
l'aménagement de cette place plusieurs
projets sont en cours d'étude
[Musique]
c'est assez émouvant de penser qu'on
engage une réflexion qui va nous
conduire à envisager toute cette place
d'armes libérer de ses voitures libérer
des autocars à un horizon qu'on ne
définit pas encore nous mêmes il s'agit
des grilles deux millions d'euros seront
consacrés pour redorer ses grilles mais
encore plus loin plus fort on veut
améliorer la question du stationnement
et la question de la circulation autour
du château quand vous arrivez devant le
château de versailles aujourd'hui vous
avez une nappe de parkings de voitures
et de bus ce qui quand même n'est pas
prêt engageant le but c'est déjà
d'écarter les autobus de ceux du coeur
de cette passe d'armes d'essayer de les
placer davantage sur les côtés pour
libérer la vision que l'on peut avoir
vers la ville et vers les écuries
ça c'est dans un premier temps et puis
ensuite c'est tout ce travail qui devra
être fait de substituer un parking au
parking de la place d'armes alors après
il ya diverses formules comme on vous
l'a dit il ya la venue de saint cloud
pour ceux qui connaissent versa il ya la
venue de paris moi même je ne suis pas
au clair sur ce que devra faire parce
qu'encore une fois les contingences
techniques sont si nombreuses qu'il faut
faire une étude d'experts le maire de
versailles françois de mazières exprime
son point de vue sur ces projets nous
sommes pas favorables pour des raisons
de fonctionnement à l'idée de partager
les bus à la fois sur le côté sud ils
n'offrent de la place aujourd'hui les
bus le côté nord c'est un aménagement
que la ville a fait lorsque je suis
devenu maire
il fonctionne très bien aussi devait
passer de l'autre côté se poserait deux
problèmes 1 quel bus vont sol parking
sur où ces parkings et deuxièmement des
brames de circulation important pour la
ville de versailles parce que pour le
coup ce serait nécessairement à tourner
à droite et là vous n'avez que deux voix
et non trois pour l'instant le coût
total de l'opération s'élève à 5
millions d'euros mais pour ces
prochaines années il pourrait s'étendre
jusqu'à 50 millions d'euros
[Musique]